we're high on a snowy mountain in
pakistan where a group of nepalese
climbers are struggling through harsh
winds
it's two o'clock
in the
evening think this is one of the hottest
climb
we have ever met
[Music]
that's ming maggioja sherpa he goes by
ming magee for short
he and his team are trying to make
history on the world's second highest
mountain the legendary k2
the team had been navigating a route to
the summit but were blocked by a
dangerous crevasse that's a deep crack
in the snow that could swallow the
climbers
so they had to retreat back to their
camp a tiny cluster of tents clinging to
the side of the mountain it is so
difficult to find a way
through the crevasse
we will
we're
so high
on the other side and we could not
cross the crevasse when we went back
and we
came
more
on the ridge towards decision sites
and finally we crossed the creepers deer
and three o'clock we muted
in game three
k2 is shorter than mount everest by
about two football fields but it's far
more difficult to climb reserved for
only the most seasoned mountaineers
in the 1950s george bell one of the
first climbers to attempt it called it a
savage mountain that tries to kill you
even in the summer it's so cold that
severe frostbite is a constant worry so
windy that climbers can be hurled off
its face
so steep that a poorly placed ice axe or
mistied rope can instantly lead to
tragedy
and ming magee and his fellow nepalese
they're attempting to do something that
many thought was impossible
even suicidal they're trying to climb k2
in winter
[Music]
i'm peter guinn editor at large at
national geographic magazine and this is
overheard a show where we eavesdrop on
the wild conversations we have here at
naggio and follow them to the edges of
our big weird beautiful world
in the mountaineering world the first
winter ascent of k2 was considered the
last unclaimed crown jewel
and for years i'd hear from climbers
about teams planning k2 winter
expeditions
but in the same breath i'd hear that
there's no way they'd actually pull it
off
this week a nepalese climber tells us
how he and his team sought to make
mountaineering history
[Music]
more after the break
winter mountaineering is actually a
fairly simple concept it's it's just
mountaineering in the coldest season of
the year
what gets a little harder to understand
is why anybody would want to do it
that's bernadette mcdonald she's a
canadian writer who covers
mountaineering climbing mountains is
hard enough but doing it in the winter
it's torture
it's brutally cold it's very lonely and
it's windy i i think what most of the
climbers complained about more than
anything more even than the temperatures
was the wind
and then there's the death zone the
region above 8 000 meters which is
slightly higher than 26 000 feet where
the air gets so thin that humans can't
survive for long without bottled oxygen
it's kind of an
inhuman kind of uh
situation
people have been climbing mountains for
sport for centuries but climbing them in
winter is a relatively new thing
i think
what in a way what we're talking about
is winter climbing in the high mountains
in the himalaya in the karakoram
and that definitely has kind of a start
date a start person
it began in an unlikely place
poland in the 1970s
what happened in poland was that they
missed out on all the big firsts
because they were
they were in post-world war ii situation
which didn't allow them to travel they
had no money they were basically locked
down
sound familiar
the crown jewels of big mountain
climbing are the 14 peaks on the planet
at the top 8 000 meters
the first climbers to sum at those peaks
brought international fame and glory
back to their countries starting with a
french team who summoned depaul's
annapurna in the summer of 1950.
three years later edmund hillary and
tenzing norgay famously climbed mount
everest and by 1964 all 14 had been
climbed all the crown jewels claimed end
of story right
but then along comes andres zavada a
polish climber
he
came up with this idea that
the way that polish climbers could
differentiate themselves and really make
a name for themselves in the history of
himalayan climbing was to go at those
peaks in winter and that had not been
done i mean they started kind of with a
bang
in 1980 zavada led an expedition to
climb everest in the winter
and his team made it to the summit
and it blew people's minds i mean they
had letters from the pope
congratulating them of course the pope
was polish but nevertheless they had a
letter from the pope
more polish climbers started going to
the high mountains in winter and a whole
new race invented by the polls was on
bang one year after the other they were
sending expeditions they were talented
they were strong they were tough
and they had all the time in the world
because they didn't have jobs
polish climbers would eventually claim
10 first ascents of the prized 8
thousanders in winter
and by 2020 all the big mountains have
been climbed in winter except for one
the savage mountain
[Music]
k2 rises in an extremely rugged and
remote part of pakistan near the border
with china
and it's so remote that it takes a week
to hike to the mountain from the nearest
village
why do you think that was that that peak
stayed unclimbed in winter you know
where the other ones had all been so
even everest had been successfully
climbed
well first of all okay it's true it's
not the highest but it's definitely the
most difficult there's just the
difficulty the steepness of the mountain
also it's further north than everest so
it is colder
and it's also at the very top of the
range so it's the first mountain it to
get the the big storms from the north so
the the winds apparently are horrendous
on k2 more so than say on on everest
unlike everest k2 requires precise
technical climbing especially near the
top even in the best conditions
for roughly every four climbers who make
it to the top of k2 and back down
another one dies in the attempt and no
team has made it even close to the top
in winter
how big a prize was this was k2 in
winter
i think that k2 in winter
was
the biggest prize that was still out
there there was so much interest in who
would climb it and how they would do it
and
there were so many
top-level himalayan climbers who were
trying it or who were thinking of trying
it so i i can't think of another prize
that was bigger than k2 in winter
mingli was among the climbers who wanted
to claim that prize
he grew up in nepal's rolling valley
located west of mount everest so we
don't have electricity we don't have
telephone lines we don't have any road
facility
so we actually we have not we have
nothing few crops can grow so high up in
the mountains
and getting food from other parts of
nepal up to where they lived was
expensive
we
live our life under candlelight
like work every day working on a field
just growing potatoes we grew up in a
very difficult life
we were the one of the most poorest
people in in nepal
but rowling is famous for one thing in
particular producing world-class
mountain guides
although super dangerous it's a job that
offers one of the few ways for many
sherpa and remote areas to earn a decent
living
and several of ming mcgee's family went
to work for outfitters helping clients
from around the world climb nepal's
biggest mountains
did your father and uncles tell you
stories about famous sherpa climbers
when you were growing up yeah a lot
ming mcgee would hear his father and
uncles talk about expeditions to several
of the eight thousanders including lotsy
in dalagiri where his father had climbed
with the legendary italian climber
reinhold messner
his first cousin lobsang jiangbu sherpa
had assisted climbers during the 1996
disaster made famous by the book into
thin air
so in 2006 when mingminji was 19
he convinced his uncle to take him on a
climb to the 8 000 meter manisolu it was
one of the
most beautiful moment of my life
after that after that i
it was like kind of more interesting
climbing then i joined another
exhibition than another than another
the experience convinced mingaji to
become a god just like his father and
uncles but his mother was not happy with
this decision
my mother my father they never wanted me
to become a mountainer
years earlier mingmiji's father had
taken a japanese climber up mount
everest and at one point his dad took
off his gloves to tie the climber's boot
laces and his hands were severely
frostbitten so my father lost eight
fingers
in that he was eight fingers
he lost it
despite what would seem to be a
career-ending injury
his father continued working as a
climbing guide he continued working with
his like very short sharp fingers and
yet his father's experience didn't stop
ming magee from climbing he loved being
in the mountains and was especially
proud of the sherpa reputation as being
among the world's strongest climbers i
can say like we are regarded as the king
on 8000 maybe i should not say this but
i know you said it man i'm not going to
disagree with you i'm not going to
disagree
because
people people are from all over the
world they hire nebula for climbing a
thousand meter peak right of course
so mingle g work for other expeditions
and eventually he built his own
successful guiding business
but there was one thing that still
bothered him
even though nepalis had been part of
teams that had claimed some of the crown
jewels since
they'd never accomplished one all on
their own
if we see
on wikipedia or on internet
like if we see the winter list there's
no any
terrible name or know any neighbor's
flag
sherpas have always been the backbone of
mountaineering in the himalayas they
haul gear and supplies help run the base
camps and if they stick with it over
time they learn to guide foreign clients
to the summits like many of his fellow
guides ming mcgee felt that nepali
climbers didn't get the same respect as
some of the celebrated foreign climbers
he realized that the way to change this
was by claiming the last major and
arguably the greatest achievement in the
big mountains summiting k2 in winter but
he also knew it meant taking a huge risk
and it was always said that we could
lose the hands
we're going to lose the fingers yeah
well and especially after your father
that it happened to him
i would imagine that was really a scary
thing if it happens to me then
i think my mother would feel more
difficult than me myself
ming magee knew what he was getting into
he climbed k2 before in fact minglij is
one of the only mountaineers who can
claim to have climbed to the top of k2
three times
no one summoned it more than that
but on those expeditions he'd had the
responsibility of leading clients
and i said like okay
now i'll go i'll go back
back on here too but i'll not lead any
clients i'll just go for myself and i go
for my nations
but there were several huge obstacles
before he even set foot on the mountain
first because of covid his guiding
business had been slow and especially
bad for a mountaineer about to tackle
the climb of his life he was out of
shape
i started working on my body
because i i need to i need to be like a
little a little more slim and
more like um
more energetic
i started cycling
running
then he had to raise money
expeditions like k2 run into the tens of
thousands of dollars
and without paying clients the funding
was all on him
so eventually mingmiji mortgaged a piece
of land he owned
and then he had to assemble a team
willing to go with him on such a risky
trip which was a huge ask of the
climbers but also of their families
like one of my sherpa he said like he
cannot he cannot go
because he does he doesn't want to lose
lose his body parts
even when he found some climbers who
wanted to go with him their wives
thought it was way too risky they
started
arguing with me
we might lose them they might lose their
fingers
and blah blah blah lots of these things
but mingmingji believed this expedition
was important
a challenge worth the risks
so we made the women a solemn promise
if their husbands died on the expedition
their families could live with him
the wives agreed and he and his team
headed to pakistan
coming up
when he reaches base camp mingminji
forms an important alliance
and on the way to the summit he finds
himself in a life-threatening situation
one that he can't turn back from
we'll have that and more after this
when mingminji and his team finally got
to k2 base camp in late december 2020
they found out they weren't the only
ones with this idea there were about 60
climbers from several nations including
another all-nepali team led by a guy
named nirmal perja who everyone called
nims
in the parlance of mountaineers
nims is a beast almost a superhero type
figure
he'd made headlines the year before when
he climbed the world's 14 tallest peaks
all the crown jewels on back to back
expeditions
in just six months and six days
just to give you some background here
the last climber who climbed them all he
did it in seven years
it's really hard to describe how
insanely difficult that feat really is
and it caught the mountaineering world
completely by surprise because the guy
just seemed to come out of nowhere
i'm still trying to figure nims out
actually what's surprising to me is that
unlike many of the guys he climbs with
he didn't really grow up in the high
mountains actually limbs comes from
chitwan
which is the tropical low altitude part
of nepal
think elephants and palm trees not giant
snow-covered mountains
but he'd spent six years in the gurkhas
which is part of the british military
and then later he joined the special
forces and served in afghanistan before
deciding to pursue a mountaineering
career
i actually caught up with nims by phone
briefly last year when he was in
kathmandu between expeditions and i
asked him about his approach to climbing
big mountains
i think the biggest thing what i have
learned from from being in special
forces is the decision-making process
and also that willingness
not to give up you know you need to have
certain you know mindset
that mindset is what i call it a
positive mindset yeah sometimes you know
you will you don't have a good day at
all yeah but if you think oh it's a [ __ ]
day if you just think negative about it
you're not gonna progress but if you
just think
in everything you can always see
positiveness
and now nims this new mountaineering
superstar has arrived in pakistan with
the same plan as ming mcgee claimed the
first winter ascent of k2
the two nepalese men knew of each other
they'd been sort of respectful rifles
they were both guides trying to build up
their own climbing resumes
i know i was competitive to him he knew
he was accommodated to me but on a
mountain like k2 where things can go
horribly wrong in a hurry mingmiji knew
that the two nepalis needed to support
each other
and if something happens to you guys
we need we must help you guys if
something happens to us then you must
help us
because
there are there will be nobody to help
on the mountain
beside helping each other
[Music]
so the teams begin climbing the mountain
hauling bottles of oxygen tents sleeping
bags and coils of rope
at progressively higher elevations they
establish tiny camps little outposts
they can use to shelter and recharge
during a final push to the summit
on new year's eve minmaji and his team
return down the mountain to rest and
analyze the weather forecasts
when they get a strange invitation
nems is throwing a party and he wants
them to come
wait a party a k2 base camp
they had got lots of whiskeys
they were they were a big team so they
had they had brought lots of whiskeys
and they they said okay let's celebrate
uh new york tonight so you guys are
there to climb a mountain it's this big
very dangerous scary mountain and you
guys are having a party at base camp i
didn't i didn't i didn't think you'd
have time or energy to party
at the party nems makes a bold
proposition
what if the two teams joined forces and
start climbing together
he argues it would be safer but also it
will increase the chances that it will
be a nepali who claims the first winter
ascent of k2
and he said like okay we're gonna we're
gonna party
for a while tonight and then tomorrow
morning we're gonna start back on the
morning i don't know it's it's not
possible
partying and then immediately heading up
the mountain seems like a bad idea to
ming maji his team needs to rest before
they start their climb
but he tells nymphs that if he wants to
leave early he can use mingy's supplies
stashed on the mountain
we have auctions at 7 000 meter we have
rope at 7000 meters you can use our
auction you can use our rope
you can use anything you you like from
my tents from my teams
the important thing mmaji says is that
the summit is claimed for nepal
if you made summit
that's that summit is not only yours
there's somebody's mind too that's
something is our nameless summit
so
you met somebody i make summit is the
same for nepal
the gesture touches newms
he had the same things he said like
this time the k2 is not for me but the
kid is for for the nations and for our
all brothers and i had the same feeling
that ketu is not for myself it is for
all neighbors
and
i think that made me
bring more closer to him
yeah it sounded like you guys trust each
other at that point that's when you
started trusting each other yeah
there's an old saying and climbing the
mountain decides
and after new year's k2 decides not to
let anyone out of base camp
hurricane-force winds sweep in forcing
everyone to hunker down in their tents
we had too much wind
i think almost like 140 kilometer per
hour
wow
we didn't we didn't have good sleep like
for almost like for three days because
it was like hitting all the nights and
all day
big wins
for two weeks the wind howls
and when it finally lets up mingmiji and
nims lead their combined team of ten
nepali climbers up the mountain
working together they make rapid
progress they take turns leading the way
setting ropes for the others to follow
and in a couple of days they're ready to
make the final push to the historic
summit
as the climbers move into the death zone
above 8 000 meters most of them start
using their bottled oxygen but minmaji
discovers a major problem his regulator
isn't working and he isn't getting
enough oxygen it didn't work then i took
one from my energy one more from my end
reciprocal that even that even didn't
work
finally he gets a third regulator to
work
but he's lost valuable time
and the lack of oxygen has caused him to
be vulnerable to the extreme cold
i was too cold
especially my feet
and i was feared to lose my feet
and
i was i was thinking very clearly my
mother's and my family because my mother
she left all all her life
seeing my father
so
that that if
i lose my fingers
if
i lose anything
she would
be crying holy whole her rest of our
life
as badly as he wants to make history for
his country mingminji makes a difficult
decision he'll give up the climb i mean
there's no mountain worth losing your
life for
he takes out his radio to call his
teammates and tell them to go on without
him
and
and as i i turn on the radio and i try
to call my ship up but the radio is off
and mingminji can't reach them
and he can't turn back without them
knowing where he is because he knows
they'll go look for him so he has to
keep going his body gets colder and
colder and he tries everything to keep
his blood moving
i spent almost like
like an hour just hitting my body
so you were hitting your body like you
were like hitting like clapping your
hands and hitting your legs right right
right right
right i try to hit lots of lots lots of
isis on the way with them with my feet
just to make myself warm
but nothing works
maymaji is afraid he's about to lose his
feet or worse
and then a miracle
the sun comes up
i sat on my back and it's been almost
like an hour just having this having sun
rays on my body just to make myself
warm when the sun started coming up that
really saved you i guess right right
[Music]
one by one the nepalis gather just below
the last slope that leads to the top at
this point mingmiji and nims as the team
leaders could claim the right to be the
first ones on the summit
i paid for my team so i could go summit
earlier than they do i could go
somewhere like like 10 10 20 steps
earlier than other other members names
could do that because he was spending
all the money for his team
but the two leaders don't want to do
that to their teams
in mountaineering history remembers
those who reached the summit first
so nims brought this idea so okay
we're gonna we got we we're gonna stop
almost like 10 to 15 meters ahead the
summit and we're gonna make a row and
we're gonna march march the summit
together
so that means like nobody is second in
the team everyone is first
so even though there were ten of you
the each one of you is the first person
to be on the top of k2 in winter right
right and then all together nepal is the
first country to be on top
right right yeah that's that's the one
the best thing
so
the nepali climbers line up ten abreast
and begin marching to the top together
and as they climb to the summit of the
planet's second highest peak in the
sub-freezing winter air
they all sing the nepali national anthem
i
i
still
cannot express these things in my words
our heart it was like full of emotions
our eyes we we had like kind of like
our eyes were watery like we had the
tears in the eyes
we caught up with nims right after the
climb 2 when he was celebrating with the
team in kathmandu can you talk a little
bit about what the reaction has been um
in nepal all my team members feel like
they're a rocky star and it's so good to
see the big smile on my team and uh
it's such a huge inspiration to the
future generation
of nepal as well
most importantly for both nems and ming
miji was that the eight men that they
recruited to help them make history all
made it back safely to their families
i was very happy that i lead a team
and everyone in the team became
safe
nothing between the team members
nobody lose nothing
i think this this is the most memorable
thing for me that in this in such
extreme weather
i i brought the dim all safely back back
to home
there are people who will hear the story
and think that's crazy
i mean why would anyone risk their life
for just being able to say you got to
the top of a mountain in winter
but there will also be people who hear
this story including nepali children
and think if ming mcgee and nims can
climb k2 in winter
what can i do
[Music]
if you like what you hear and you want
to support more content like this please
rate and review us in your podcast app
and please consider a national
geographic subscription that's the best
way to support overheard go to
natgeo.com
explore to subscribe
want to actually see that moment when
nepali climbers summit k2 singing their
national anthem
luckily for us they took a video check
it out on nem's instagram account at
nimsdie
of course there's a whole lot more to
this dramatic k2 expedition and if you
want to learn more check out our
magazine story which includes a detailed
map of the mountain it's in the february
issue of national geographic
plus nemesis got a new memoir out about
climbing the 14 highest peaks in the
world in record time it's called beyond
possible i've read it and i couldn't put
it down
also if you're wondering about the
polish climbers who started this winter
climbing craze
check out bernadette mcdonald's book
freedom climbers it's a fascinating read
that's all in the show notes they're
right there in your podcast app
this week's overheard episode is
produced by elana strauss our producers
are kari douglas and marcy thompson our
senior producers are brian gutierrez and
jacob pinter
eli chen is our senior editor carla
wills is our manager of audio
our executive producer of audio is d'var
artilon
our fact checkers are robin palmer and
julie beer
hansdale sue composed our theme music
and also sound designed and engineered
this episode
this podcast is a production of national
geographic partners whitney johnson is
the director of visuals and immersive
experiences
david brindley is national geographic's
interim editor-in-chief
and i'm your host peter gwynne thanks
for listening and see y'all next time
[Music]
[Music]
you